six feet
[Music]
because I'm angry
it is a shame I'm 6 to 9 years old I was
part of the dr. King's movement in
Atlanta Georgia I'm from Atlanta it's
important to me to be out here to
support the cause and let people know
that black lives matter and I wish a
Karen would okay all right the right
person like we have caused so much
destruction in our history
everybody is limited per their
perspective so while you may think you
know everything
you only know everything of your
perspective my perspective is different
than my neighbors but that doesn't mean
that their perspective is not relevant
so have ears have a heart in the end
everything really is about love not hate
as a black man I just want to be equal I
don't even I don't want to be ahead I
don't want to be below I just want an
even playing field for myself it's
important to be inclusive it's important
to recognize that all black lives matter
especially queer trans lives and we have
to really help them especially the most
marginalized of the community a lot of
people have voices of privilege and it
would be wrong to not use that privilege
right now especially when a lot of
people are listening anti blackness and
racism is very prevalent in our medical
field our education field and the arts
in every single facet of life so the
idea of fast-like fighting for black
lives is not radical it's fighting for
neighbors is fighting for doctors is
fighting for lawyers it's fighting for
the guy on the street every life that
you see is being threatened if you're
not fighting for black lives it's an
election year
it's 2020 and 20 20 means no having a
perfect vision so my vision is that we
dude wake up and try to fix inequality
and and to make it a better society for
not just me but for my future
generations
I believe that every man and woman
that's in authority has been placed
there by God and I say that to say that
they have a divine responsibility to
treat people fairly the three people in
our in a divine manner in a godly manner
I mean they truly have a responsibility
you know there there's so many people in
denial about what's happening in the
world but you can't deny what's
happening you can't deny the hurt the
pain that's going on like it's amplified
there's people in the streets fighting
for it so I'm here to tear down what has
been built for the last hundreds of
years just being a part of history and I
mean a lot of people are sending hate
for being here and they think like oh
you guys marched enough like all the
issues are solved like no they're not
there's so many issues educate people
and support like crazy because if we
stop supporting if we let the moment
pass then this is all gonna pass and
we're not going to make the big change
that we need to make in the country in
order for anyone to be free we all have
to feel like there's a freedom available
to all of us for the first time in my
lifetime I'm realizing and seeing
visually and hearing from all people
from all walks of life that are actually
sharing the same message and it gives me
a lot of hope you know
I'm heartbroken but I'm hopeful at the
same time so it's not about silencing
other voices it's about making sure that
we're heard because we are we have not
been heard for centuries yes okay since
slavery and
and you know people want to say slavery
was in the past but no slavery is still
happening to this day look at our motion
system look at the way in which black
people being treated look at the way
mass incarceration czar being treated
they're acting as if they're like
overseers it's a big movement you know
what I mean and in the histories here
the traumas here the anger is here the
frustration is here the sadness is here
like everything the the emotions here
and I think it's a lot more than that as
well so I just think being out here is
very important it's time for it's time
for them to see us no justice no peace
[Music]
it is a shame when a young black
african-american man is afraid to walk
the streets in my 69 years I've never
seen anything like this
if we don't change now it would never
change this is blood on our hands
America
the whole nation the whole world sees it
down so what are we gonna do in my
hometown just a few nights to go the
same thing happen a young black man is
running away from the ponies he'd get
killed
I'm hurt I share my hurt I take your her
and I and let me absorb the hurt but we
have to come together god bless you and
God bless america